[Música]
o tema central ida tem sido a comida cá
porque entrei de história
a primeira história se passa às vésperas
da segunda guerra mundial em uma pequena
cidade chamada don't prova entre
alemanha e romênia
havia uma linda menina loira de cabelos
cacheados de olhos azuis de 13 anos
o nome dela era magda ela era a terceira
filha de uma família de judeus que
viviam em uma casa grande de tijolos com
muitos quartos muitos quadros muitos
empregados
um dos empregados da casa era o michel
michel era um rapaz forte olhos verdes
de 17 anos ele era o faz-tudo da casa da
família de magda e ele tinha uma paixão
secreta não correspondida por magda
magda nem sabia de sua existência
os alemães invadem a polônia
a família de magda é presa perde todos
os seus bens ea mandada para o campo de
concentração de auschwitz onde começam a
passar muito frio e muita fome
a família de maria então é separada de
cada um é determinado na câmara de gás
magda por diversas vezes vai ter fila da
câmara de gaia
milagrosamente ela sobrevive
ela passa a ser um número 50 950 tatuado
em seu antebraço
ela fica presa em áudio e vídeo dos 14
aos 18 anos e quando acabar a guerra ela
está pesando 30 quilos
michel por sua vez foge para a sibéria
com seu irmão mais novo onde também
passam o frio e muita fome
o irmão de michel não sobrevive e morre
michel então é preso e mandado para o
campo de trabalho forçado e lá algumas
vezes dão pra ele batata todos os tipos
de batata para ele comia e uma família
que teve o filho morto na guerra dá pra
ele um casaco e assim por sorte
michel sobrevive esse aqui é o michel
quando acaba a guerra
michel volta pra dombrova antiga cidade
à procura de alguém que ele conhecesse
toda a sua família morreu lá e não prova
ele escuta falar que magnata seu antigo
amor tinha sobrevivido mas ela foi
mandada para munique para o campo de
refugiados rapidamente
michel vai para munique e procura na
lista de sobreviventes do nome de magda
michel e magda se reencontram
eles se casam eles têm uma filha chamada
eva
eles decidem que não querem ficar na
alemanha na alemanha do pós-guerra e por
terem parei distantes no braço
eles pegam navio na terceira classe do
navio passando fome e vem para o rio de
janeiro
eva é minha mãe porque que eu tô
contando essa história e porque essa
história pra mim é tão importante
primeiro porque é uma história real
depois porque é uma linda história de
amor pra mostrar que o improvável pode
acontecer e que a sorte pode estar do
nosso lado mas que pra isso tudo
aconteça a gente tem que ter muita garra
muita coragem e muita confiança
essa foto é de uma família totalmente
improvável de acontecer
meu avô michel a minha avó magda com os
seis bisnetos ea minha mãe eva com seis
né
meu avô me é antes de morrer me disse
que o que fez ele sobreviver não foram
nem as batatas e nem o casaco e sim ele
ainda poderá acreditar que existiam
pessoas boas no mundo
apesar de tudo o que ele estava passando
a segunda história começa na infância eu
sou a terceira filha de duas irmãs
gêmeas
eu sempre fui conhecida como avulsa e
nas brincadeiras com as minhas irmãs
eu tinha dois papéis fundamentais sem os
quais a brincadeira não podia acontecer
o eu era a árvore ou era o sinal de
trânsito
eu ainda podia escolher entre uma e
outra
as lembranças mais antigas mais remotas
que eu tenho da minha ânsia as
lembranças mais remotas que eu tenho da
minha infância são meus avós do chef
aguda trazendo amor e afeto todos os
dias pra minha casa e em forma de pão de
queijo
dellatorre sorvete de filé mignon on
eu aprendi durante toda a minha vida que
alimentar é da amor e que o amor vem
pela comida
é meus pais trabalhavam muito meus avós
me apanhavam na natação e no inglês ea
gente ia direto comeu uma coxinha de
galinha
assim eu me sentia conectada e eu me
sentia amada
essa foto sou eu
aos 12 anos sendo muito alimentada e
muito amado
até que na minha adolescência eu começa
a questionar os valores da minha família
como uma boa adolescente
o meu padrão de amor passa a ser a
magreza ea minha auto-estima medida em
gramas e eu começa então um processo de
anorexia
eu passei mais de um ano a ano
técnica emagrecendo a cada dia
por mais que eu emagrecesse eu nunca me
sentia satisfeita com o meu próprio
corpo e todos os dias as minhas metas de
emagrecimento e um piorando
foi um período muito doloroso e sofrido
pra mim solitário
é como se eu tivesse aprisionada dentro
da minha própria em ti e como se eu
tivesse também competindo comigo mesma
era uma guerra sem vencedor e sem fim
eu tinha uma agenda onde eu anotava as
minhas estratégias de guerra
eu sentia dores na barriga eu não podia
contar pra ninguém porque eu não podia
ser derrotado naquela guerra eu anotava
também nessa agenda à noite o alimento
que eu pararia de comer no dia seguinte
e assim sucessivamente um dia eu tirava
massa outro pão outro doce e do final de
um ano eu estava comendo só cenoura e as
minhas mãos amarelas hoje eu fiquei esse
um ano sem metrô a minha mãe me obrigava
a fazer exames de sangue todos os meses
um dia eu estava em casa com a minha mãe
ligaram do laboratório perguntando se eu
tinha sofrido um acidente porque eu
estava com anemia muito profunda
neste momento eu tive muito medo de
morrer
não por falta de amor e fim de comida e
comecei então um processo de cura
aos 24 anos formado em economia na puc
eu fui morar em nova york com meu
namorado que hoje é meu marido e eu
comecei a trabalhar no mercado
financeiro lá em nova york
eu substituía a competição contra mim
mesmo da anorexia por longas horas de
trabalho um trabalho altamente
competitivo
eu vivia no piloto automático como se eu
fosse um ratinho dentro de uma roda e
aquele não era o meu sonho
apesar
eu não sabia naquele momento qual ele
qual ele seria e lá eu comecei a ter
ataques de pânico e meu chefe americano
me mandava para o banheiro até que meu
ataque de pânico passar se eu voltasse
pra mesa para trabalhar mas lá também
trabalhando com esses americanos eu
descobria que eu tinha um espírito
empreendedor
aos 32 anos ainda trabalhando no mercado
financeiro
eu tive meu primeiro filho felipe e eu
parei de trabalhar logo depois eu tive
meu segundo filho joão e foi o primeiro
momento da minha vida em que eu fiquei
oito anos sem trabalhar e sem estudar
eu fiquei oito anos somente nutrindo os
meus filhos e foi nesse período da
maternidade que eu consegui elaborar
toda a minha história de vida de meus
avós passaram fome na guerra e não
tiveram amor eu na infância eu tive
muita comida e famoso
na adolescência eu tive comida me privei
da comida eu me privei do amor e eu me
privei do prazer e agora na maternidade
era a primeira vez na vida que eu
entendia que amor comida e nutrição
podiam se andar juntos
mas o meu pavor em alimentar bem os meus
filhos foi tamanho que eu fui estudar
sobre alimentos e até parado por aqui
mas foi nesse momento ainda tentando
elaborar um equilíbrio entre a subir
alimentação e a superalimentação eu
percebia que eu tinha uma sementinha
muito fraca de um sonho brotando dentro
do meu peito e entende nesse momento que
a marca comercial mas amar é comer bem
amar é alimentar a alma e percebi que
principalmente nós mulheres gastamos
muito do nosso tempo da nossa energia
pensando se a gente tá gorda ou se a
gente está magra ao nosso percentual de
gordura
é olhando instagram pra ver de ginástica
que a gente tem que fazer usando a
nutrição pra emagrecer sempre esquece a
nutrição mais importante é no trio os
nossos sonhos
a terceira história sobre sonhos eu vou
falar do meu sonho mas eu queria que
vocês pensassem no sonho de vocês
numa viagem de férias pois meu filho
no avaí eu conheci os sucos prensados a
frio no primeiro bole eu senti o imenso
prazer e não sente culpa com uma ex
anoréxica
eu não entendia nada de sul muito menos
prensados a frio quando entendia que o
método de prensagem a frio preserva
todos os nutrientes todos os sabores não
têm conservantes não tem choque térmico
não tem pasteurização eu decidir que eu
abriria a primeira empresa de suco
pensado no rio de janeiro
eu encontrei aquele sabor naquele suco
tudo que eu achava de mais importante
quero prazer a nutrição eo sabor e
naquele momento do meu sonho eu decidi
que eu envolveria o maior número de
nutricionistas e médicos de saúde que eu
procuraria os melhores ingredientes as
melhores frutas as melhores
funcionalidades as melhores combinações
e que eu teria um desafio de provar que
apesar de saudáveis os sucos sim
poderiam ser gostosa da minha empresa eu
sou cliente mais chata e eu coloco o
melhor de mim dentro da garrafa
só que isso tudo aconteceu sem desafio à
logística resfriada num país tropical
não era diária as compras eram diárias o
suco só durava três dias porque não têm
conservantes pra ser sincera eu não
tinha a menor idéia
fazer essa empresa funcionar essa é a
primeira máquina de suco pensado que eu
trouxe uma mala de viagem com meu marido
reclamando do peso e esses primeiros
jogos que eu produzir na minha cozinha
três anos e meio atrás
e essa foto não parecia nada promissor
nesse momento eu entendia que se a gente
esperar ter as condições ideais para
começar o nosso sonho a gente nunca
começa e as pessoas me achavam maluca me
davam argumentos racionais pra gente pra
eu o pasteurizar o congelar o suco para
aquele durasse mais tempo mas aquele não
era o meu sonho e eu não ia tomar
atalhos aquele não era o melhor de mim
dentro da garrafa
eu pensei em desistir por diversas vezes
eu costumo dizer que empreender no
brasil como videogame todos os dias ou a
gente morre ou a gente passa de fato um
sentimento tarde empreende neste país e
eu não desistir
eu tive a sorte de encontrar sócios com
habilidades complementares à minha e
hoje junto com 150 o melhor de mim na
garrafa
virou o melhor de nós na garrafa e o que
me estimula
é eu ver o sonho de cada pessoa que
trabalha comigo aconteceu dentro do meu
sonho como por exemplo o caso da rebeca
ela foi a minha primeira funcionária e
ela é a primeira pessoa da família dela
fazer faculdade
ela começou do chão da fábrica
literalmente descascando abacaxi
depois ela foi trabalhar na logística
ela foi trabalhar na área comercial
ela foi abrir nosso primeiro quiosque e
hoje é gerente de vários filósofos isso
tudo e meio
a cultura da oportunidade e do
companheirismo é o que me dá garra pra
que essa empresa
a única empresa de sucos no brasil que
temos uma máquina alta pressão que após
o suco engarrafado simula que a pela
pressão que a garrafa para o ponto mais
fundo do oceano
matam as bactérias todas e preservando
os nutrientes fazendo com que o suco que
durava três dias hoje e dura até 60 dias
improvável pode acontecer é nos momentos
difíceis que são quase todos eu resgato
na minha história familiar
os ingredientes que me motivaram a
construção desse sonho e sempre me
lembro da história dos meus avós que
improvável pode acontecer a sorte pode
estar do nosso lado e que pra isso
aconteça a gente tem que ter muita garra
muita coragem e muita confiança e da
próxima vez que você viu essa garrafa
receba todo meu amor e pense no seu
sonho
pense também na sua história familiar
porque quando voltando do nosso olhar
pra dentro da nossa família
achamos as inspirações para as nossas
vidas
essas relações familiares que nos
diferenciam do resto da nossa turma ea
nossa liderança está na capacidade de
fazermos a diferença mesmo que achamos
que nossa família disfuncional
eu achava que a minha família
disfuncional
a gente acha inspirações para a nossa
vida e as inspirações mais do que nunca
com esse mundo a gente olhando pra fora
e pra ídolos fora eles podem estar
dentro da nossa família e pra terminar
eu te pergunto aonde você coloca o seu
melhor
obrigada gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]